alors la légion étrangère à la popote et
j'aimerais toucher rapidement à la botte
oui à la pâte seconde matam
j'écoute j'écoute ouais j'ai parlé à
raymond
je voudrais parler un mot c'est moi même
c'est quel sujet ben oui c'est qui ça je
vois pas la jeune femme avec l'arrogance
a un pois bleus ouais au toit j'étais
tellement bourré ça va tu me manques tu
me manques et moi je te moques bah ouais
ouais bon gestionnaire voilà bien violer
tu parles d'une j'avais ouais rien je
t'adore
en tout cas dit et et merci pour le
petit cadeau un petit cadeau le fruit d'
que j'ai trouvé d'un magot death merci à
tétouan mais non c'est chouette si tout
le monde était comme vous ça vaudrait la
peine non mais tout de même c'est
chouette ce qui compte c'est que je
puisse tentant pardon jeudi
ce qui compte c'est que je puisse
entendre pas voir ses audiences je
répète répéter j'ai pas compris
jeudi l'important c'est que nous
puissions nous entendre sur les prix
alors oui ça me consoler un peu de
pouvoir téléphoner je te dérange pas
bastien sais que je pourrai pas aux
causes et lanta gp tête m occuper je
raccroche dans une seconde je te prends
mais simplement je voulais tu as fait
avant de partir je m'envole pour paris
dans une heure ça va c'est pour - qui
n'ont pas ri oui genre grâce à paris 7
où 1
jeudi c'est tout ce que tu as à me dire
bah ouais
et puis merci pourquoi le petit cadeau
oui tu as bu un abus bah ouais voir
madame on se reverra plus vraiment et
c'est un peu de chance de ce soir nous
n'étions pas destiné à nous rencontrer
marqué dans notre cas c'était plutôt le
genre bref vos rencontres callebaut
films téléfilms brève rencontre radieux
rameau ben ahmed m athieu répond mais
moi je vous prêter